it's time for another monthly update
video we're already one week into August
2016 so for all of my viewers
subscribers followers whatever the
description happens to be that people
were interested in the kind of work that
I'm doing through my company reason I oh
this is what we've got coming up in
august and what went on in july so i
like to begin every time by talking
about three big things this month two of
the big things are things happening this
month one is something happening next
month but which you can sign up for this
month you'll see links to all of them in
the video description below so if any of
this sounds interesting to you check
them out and bookmark them and get
involved big thing number one we are
partnering with out school to offer some
seminars for homeschooling parents and
children those who would be interested
in beefing up their education by
bringing in some classical philosophy
what we're doing is bringing in some
discussion of plato i'm going to offer
some seminars providing an introduction
to platonic philosophy more about that
in the august portion of this the second
big thing we are partnering with another
institution the partially examined life
this one's for adults right and what
we're going to do is offer a seminar on
Hagel's master-slave dialectic two-hour
seminar towards the end of the month as
part of the not school reading groups
that they do we're offering it through
reason i owe is something new for us you
know these one-off seminars that we're
going to do monthly but it's also
connecting up with their community of
people who are passionate about
philosophy the third big thing is
something i'm really happy about
starting in September actually on
September 11th we've got another online
class this is one's a four week class
coming up this one is on niches birth of
trash
majid e so if you've ever wanted to
study this this interesting early work
of Nietzsche where he's introducing the
idea of the opposition between the
Apollonia and the DNS Ian you're going
to want to get in on this and I'll tell
you more about that in in the August
portion just a little bit about that but
you can also click on the link below and
it'll tell you more about it as well so
what went on in the month of july i
actually did quite a bit but I I also
backed off quite a bit as well in part
because um i had my children visiting
for the summer and we did a lot of
activities oriented around that as a
family we also went to our annual
three-day family reunion for those who
don't know i come from a pretty massive
family are our reunions a small one is
about 90 people big one is about a
hundred and fifty people and we get
together every year for three days out
in Illinois so that was a lot of a lot
of fun a lot of good downtime and some
relaxation I also ended up doing a few
talks we try to cut back on those a
little bit in the summer months but i
did talk at the brookfield public
library you can see the video links to
these below on Roger Zelazny and his
Chronicles of amber series so it was
entitled Roger Zelazny amber and chaos
and we're looking at philosophical
themes this is part of that worlds of
speculative fiction series that I do I
also gave a talk towards the end of the
month at the Wauwatosa Public Library
they invited me back to talk more about
existentialism this time going into
specific themes and so the two themes
that I picked this time were anxiety and
human freedom had some great discussion
some great question again the videos
linked to below we also had our monthly
heffa or Hagel public Q&A session and
that was pretty much it as far as events
went I got a bit of writing done a
little bit of work on the academic
writing that I'm trying to do I'd
a little bit of writing in half hour
Hagel and inner exes do you know aunty
came but I also brought out a piece in
in stoicism today and the editor as you
know stoicism today and one of the
benefits of that is that I get to write
pieces occasionally that that I want to
sneak in there I've been doing a series
on stoicism and an anger and the
resources that stoicism provides for
dealing with anger so I've been working
on epictetus in particular I did a piece
back in April and then a piece or may
perhaps and that a piece recently in
July on epictetus and dealing with your
own anger it's not a complete discussion
of that there's more coming up that I'll
talk about in the August portion I also
did quite a bit of coaching you know you
do executive coaching and I did some
philosophical counseling and some
tutorial sessions as well with
interested students there's not quite so
much of that during the summer months
but I still get quite a few clients I
did some video work as well five
half-hour Hagel videos in the series
I've also continued releasing the the
videos produced for the aristotle class
which was back earlier this this spring
I've been bringing out those core
concept videos videos of the talks you
can see those link below and I've also
started producing something that you'd
have to do a little digging to find but
I'll leave that to you any of you who
want to do that as a challenge I've been
producing videos that are sort of like
the half-hour Hagel videos they're very
close readings you see the text up on
the screen then I give a discussion of
that a commentary and I've been doing it
for epic Titus's enchiridion going
through it chapter by chapter line by
line talking about you know examples
what do you know how it connects with
his other stoic you know passages and in
other places lots of really close
reading of that and I've been doing that
for okay here's another thing that went
on during the month of July the
epictetus and
and discourses class that I'm currently
teaching it's an online class six weeks
long we've got quite a few students
enrolled and some great discussions
going on we're now in week 3 of that
class and so I've been developing some
more resources and some of those
resources are these commentary videos
those students of course get a first
look at them as part of the reward for
you know being members of the class
right but eventually they're going to be
there for the general public I'm
thinking about releasing them during
stoic week 2016 but if you know where to
look for them then you can easily find
them so that is what went on during the
month of July what's coming up in august
well August is a considerably busier
month than July was or even June was
we've got a number of events some of
them local and some of them online so i
want to bring each of those to your
attention and i do have to apologize one
of these events you can't go to because
it already happened so today's the
seventh it happened on the second and
that was a talk at the frank Weinberg
library which is here locally we do a
quarterly series with them called
philosophers in the midst of history
where I'm taking a you know great
philosophical figure like Aristotle or
an somewhere in this case Rene Descartes
and connecting themselves connecting
them up with their historical context so
this was on Rene Descartes the Wars of
Religion and the beginnings of modernity
we had some really great discussions you
can see the video of it if you're
interested in that link to below this is
also one of those sort of things that if
you're you know not here and you want to
bring me in to give a talk about that
sort of thing well you you know that's
that's a live possibility as I'll talk
about that a little bit more later on on
the 11th at 7pm what we've got coming up
is another one of these lectures /
discussions at the brookfield public
library in the worlds of speculative
fiction series this time it
on a person who i've been reading since
middle school I started out reading her
wizard of Earthsea trilogy and then the
beginning place and other stuff Ursula
Kayla Queen great uh you know and what
was called new wave science fiction /
fantasy writer somebody whose works i
really really enjoy so I'm hoping for
some great discussion there on the
seventeenth 526 p.m. central time it's
important that you get the time right
because this is an online event we have
our monthly half-hour Hagel public Q&A
session which we do through a google
hangout and I put the link to that in my
you know Facebook and Twitter and Google
Plus and also on my patreon page it you
know right before because I open it up
right that's the way Google Hangouts
work now if you're interested in this
you do not need to be a Patrian backer
in order to do that you just find the
link and pop in at the right time which
5 to 6 p.m. central time on august
seventeenth and you're perfectly welcome
to come in anything you want to talk
about anything you want to discuss Hagel
related I am up for I give priority to
those who have questions first and try
to answer their questions so you know
feel free to do that we also have two
things coming up with the out school two
different seminars although they're
actually the same summoners to two
sections of the same seminar one is on
Wednesday August 10th the other is on
Wednesday August twenty-fourth each of
these is for you know middle schoolers
high schoolers ages 12 through 19 if if
you have a kid who's particularly bright
and you want them to get some
introduction to some some philosophical
ideas this is on plato and i'll be
talking about Plato's importance how to
read platonic texts you know how to make
you know
the differentiation between what's going
on with play-doh and what Socrates might
be saying how to think critically is
we're reading these how to how to
examine the arguments and we'll all
answer a lot of questions of course for
students and for for parents so this is
primarily for homeschoolers but that's
not to say that students who are
enrolled at other places can't do it
they are at 11am in the morning central
standard time so most schools aren't
actually starting yet so people who are
enrolled in public school or parochial
school or private school can get in on
it but these are primarily through
throughout school which is a
homeschooling resource so if you're
interested in that the link is below on
the 30th we have our first reason I owe
intensive seminar connected with you
know some readings ahead of time in this
case Hagel's master-slave dialectic in
his phenomenology of spirit I'm
providing my own videos in the half hour
hagel series is a useful resource for
people and I will be leading discussion
but i'll be doing a lot of you know
Socratic questioning and a lot of you
know directing people to the text and
we're going to hopefully have some great
discussion going there's 20 seats
available although you know quite a few
of them are already been taken up we're
gonna have a link below that you can you
can follow if you're interested in
participating in it that is going to be
August 30th 6 to 8 p.m. central time so
if you're interested in some intensive
study of probably the most important
passage in Hegel's phenomenology at
least from the perspective of
continental philosophy you probably want
to get in on that we're going to do more
of these each month not just on hagel
we're going to have some descarte coming
up some can't coming up some play-doh so
all sorts of people so that's all the
stuff event wise that we've got going on
we're also gearing up for the fall we
have a lot of planning to do weird
being a lot of outreach to local and to
you know in some cases national
organizations putting some some speaking
and workshop engagements on the calendar
for fall for for winter we're also
looking ahead to 2017 and doing some
planning for that so if you're
interested in booking me to come in and
get the talk or workshop you can always
reach me at Greg at reason I oh send me
whatever it is that you're interested in
in proposing and we'll talk about it I'm
always happy to engage with people who
see some value to philosophy whether in
a public sense or a professional sense
or a practical sense or even in a
lifelong learning manner so we've got a
lot of that going on behind the scenes
I'm also trying to get some writing done
some of it is academic writing things
that I've you know had on the back
burner for a while some of it is more
popularly oriented writing like the
stuff on stoicism and anger not all of
which is showing up in the blogs because
I'm working on a book on stoicism and
anger as well as on Aristotle and anger
and I'm going to be doing some blogging
in half hour Hagel and our exes do you
know NTK and if I get around to it heavy
metal philosopher I'd love to get that
blog up and running again I'm also going
to be bringing out another piece in
stoicism today this month about
epictetus and anger bringing that to a
close offering more advice about how to
deal with one's own anger and if I have
the time so I'm not making a definite
promise about this but I hit if I have
the time I'm going to also do some one
or more blog pieces for the partially
examined life they invited me to blog
you know it's over a year ago and I
haven't taken advantage of that I really
want to start doing that not only to
reach a wider audience of their you know
members and participants but also
because you know it's it's nice to when
somebody asks you to follow through all
that sort of thing so got some video
work coming
as well half-hour Hagel hopefully get
all six videos out for this month more
Aristotle videos coming up a lot of
great stuff there if you're into
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics or virtue
ethics in general I'm still working on
the epictetus enchiridion videos but I'm
going to keep those unlisted for a while
those are for my students in the class
but I will be releasing them in October
for for stoic week and I'm also going to
be producing some videos for the niche
of birth of tragedy class that will be
coming up in September now that one is
going to start enrolling well before
September we're going to open up
enrollment probably about you know
actually about a week from now I think
and so you should look for a video
specifically about that class coming out
there's also a few other things I need
to do is for my video channels you know
to create some some some news new
content that people see when they come
to it a new introduction video I'd like
to do a video specifically about my
tutorial services because people they
asked a lot about that I want to do a
video specifically about philosophical
counseling because people have been
asking for that and I'd also like to
start doing more of these doctors they
have the respond videos but that's
that's a lot of stuff on the docket
we'll see how much of it I can actually
get accomplished during the month of
August good to have a lot of goals it's
even better to accomplish them though
isn't it so I wish all of you a great
month of ahead in this month of August
what's left of it we're already a week
in and hopefully I'll run into you or
see you online at one place or another